i love exploring ancient mathematics
because the ancient mathematicians had
to make decisions had to
work things out without the tools that
we have today
so how do they do it well the greatest
of them all was archimedes
and he found the volume of a sphere
how did he do it well we think
it may have gone like this he produced a
cylinder
and a sphere and something called a
double nap code
so there's a sphere and the cylinder is
the same width and the same height
it could have made them out of wood or
clay pottery i don't know
but anyway he had them made or made them
himself and this double nap cone which
is two cones that meet
in the middle once again same width same
height
so he thought about this he thought if i
take a line across the top of these
the cross section of that equals the
cross section of that
plus zero at the north pole here
right if i take a line halfway down
then the cross section of that equals
the cross section of that
plus zero here
does that mean that if i take any
horizontal line through the three
fingers
then the cross section of that will
equal the cross section of that plus the
cross section of that
every single time and he said
i bet it does but how could he prove it
simple he dunked this in water let it
settle and measure the level of the
water
took it out again dunk these two in the
same water
and the water came up to exactly the
same level
so the volume of that plus that equals
the volume of that qed
so what was that volume well he knew
that a cone
was one third of the cylinder it would
fit into
just like a pyramid is one third of the
cuboid
that would fit into get a pyramid build
the walls up for the top and
it's the third and i can prove that
because i've got three pyramids here
can you see instead of the point being
in the middle
it's on one corner and because of that
you can actually
reassemble them these three identical
pyramids
to make a cube
which proves that each is one-third of
the volume of the cube so that is
one-third the volume
of that then that is two-thirds volume
of that
well the cylinder end is pi r squared
and this is the same height and the same
width
it's two r down here because it's two
radiuses two radiuses or a diameter pi
r squared times two r which is two
pi r cubed so that is a third of it
so it's two thirds pi r cubed so this
must be twice that
four over three pi r cubed
this episode has been supported by
kiwiko redefining what it means to play
with these fantastic crates that make
everyone feel like an engineer or
designer or
frankly a bit of a genius today i'm
making an electric
pencil sharpener everything i need is
here batteries
are included and this isn't just going
to sharpen pencils
the build's really sharpening my
critical thinking and problem-solving
skills
it's just so satisfying seeing it all
come together and i really feel like i'm
learning how it all works
how all the pieces combined and with a
lot of us spending a lot of time at home
these days what a great way to occupy
the future geniuses
in your household you can see here all
sorts of crates are available
delivered right to your door and for 50
off your first one
go to kiwico.com number file
there it is on the screen kiwico.com
number far
now i know you probably think these are
mainly for kids and they're also a great
gift
but i can vouch for the fact older kids
love them as well
and there is one seriously sharp pencil